quand vous avez ouvert votre programme
télé dimanche soit vous avez été
nombreux à vous demander qu'est ce qui a
piqué la première chaîne pour programmer
le film qu'est ce qu'on a fait au bon
dieu
car oui si le film a été un franc succès
au cinéma depuis une affaire de viol a
touché l'acteur ary abittan ary abittan
et habitant mise en examen pour viol
depuis il se fait donc discret sur les
écrans mais tf1 a décidé de maintenir sa
diffusion
une décision qui a donc suscité de
nombreuses réactions sur les réseaux
pourquoi ary abittan passe à la télé si
certains s'interrogent d'autres dénonce
carrément une banalisation du viol de la
part de tf1 quand les grandes chaînes
cesseront tel d'entretenir la culture du
viol au profit leur seule audience alors
comprenez vous le déferlement contre tf1
après avoir programmé qu'est ce qu'on a
fait au bon dieu
merci myriam palombes à d'être avec nous
directrice générale
gérée clé de la rédaction de public
alors on va voir une scène de questions
de forme au lieu où le personnage que
joue harry se dispute avec son beau
frère le film c'est un bonheur hier
franchement de le revoir 5,7 millions
téléspectateurs il ya plein de gens qui
ont créé au scandale de dire pourquoi
vous avez diffuser ce film est ce que
vous comprenez le déferlement je
voudrais d oui et des non si vous avez
des petites pancartes et mènerait pas
grand chose à faire dans cette émission
de cet
oubli notre rendez-vous et oublie ma
banque je peux toujours brosser pour ted
à financer d'autres projets fois au
téléphone dit m tu crois que j'ai besoin
de toi je vais plus de contacts dans les
banques que tu en auras jamais beaucoup
aimé toi la page les temps ont changé
les flèches dans la finance y terminer
c'est nous maintenant les noix charbon
de vent en poupe et on va tous rachetés
tôt dori l'équipe a et même israël sur
la tronche de ma grand mère je vais te
défoncer la gueule elle vient enfin la
sphère 50 craquer tu vas comprendre la
douleur ça ne revient pas si
j'interviens je me couche tous les deux
non
voilà c'est toujours un bonheur de voir
les extraits de ce film qui comprend
j'aurais dit oui vous comprenez pourquoi
on comprend tout à fait la polémique non
parce que non c'est moche non moi aussi
moi je comprends pas du tout la
politique que soit la manière dont on
regarde le film vous êtes fous on le
regarde aa je réponds à la question on
le regarde à l'aune de ce qui s'est
passé mais dans la réalité on n'a pas
été condamné bien entendu sur une
présomption d'innocence abidal mais je
vous dis que c'est presque de la
provocation de le diffuser révocation
convocation pour la victime présumée toi
et même pour lui sarr mais je trouve que
ça remet sur le tapis la finale dont on
a besoin de fonds dont il était un des
coupables on n'a vraiment pas dit sa
présomption d'innocence pour moi il
n'aurait pas fallu programmer ça parce
que notre vision est perverti par la
faire c'est desservir le film c'est
desservir arrêt habitants et la victime
présumée voilà l'adage programme est
inscrite sans qu'ils ne sachent pas une
madame pas
ça va quand le public est au
pouvoir dans mon choix
non mais juridiquement raison pour
toutes ces techniques en raid et allez-y
il dit des trucs au sens où je sais que
non mais j'ai eu nicolas excusez moi
mais on s'en fout là c'est jury on s'en
fou rire autant qu'on annule
potentiellement des spectacles d'art y
habitant ça me gêne et je trouve ça
sévère parce que les gens choisissent
d'y aller ou pas là ça me gêne pour deux
raisons déjà parce qu'on impose à des
millions de téléspectateurs un film dont
l'un des protagonistes est mis en examen
ensuite je vais m'expliquer les
critiques et ensuite parce que dans ce
film on le voit quand même dans le cadre
d'une relation amoureuse avec une femme
et qui dit fit alors rendez compte on
pourrait demander des comptes que vous
allez chercher
parce que ça gênait plein de genres et
des regards des 2
5 millions c'est pas bon mais mon
message c'est pourquoi on voir et
habitants pourquoi il est arrivé de
regarder c'est quoi la référence est
flatteur non mais je comprends les gens
puissent vivre en paix ça c'est toi mais
ils m'ont peut on peut le commerçant qui
conquit le distraire les gens mais c'est
vrai qu'à la présomption d'innocence oui
je comprends tout à fait ce que dit
guillaume parce que soyons tous honnêtes
la première chose qu'on a vu à lyon la
programmation s'est dit au
premier truc qu'on s'est tous dit oui
évidemment bien sûr après tu moi j'ai
évidemment que les premières scènes on
ne peut pas s'empêcher d'y penser et de
se dire il y voit là il est dans cette
dans cette histoire là est ce que c'est
vrai ce que c'est pas vrai et c voilà
mais merci non mais évidemment voyons
soyons honnêtes en revanche tf1 n'avait
pas le choix vous pouvez pas faire
autrement non mais le début
il y avait une présence en 1905 et pays
pauvres ils pouvaient pas sinon on leur
aurait dit ben vous condamnez de fait
vous vous prenez pour la justice quelles
sont les dernières informations sur
cette affaire parce que c'est vrai que
j'ai hâte de voir ce que pensent les
téléspectateurs est ce qu'ils ont été
choqués ou pas ici oui on voit que la
plupart disent non et c'est vrai que sur
twitter sur les réseaux sociaux il ya
plein de gens qui ont dit pourquoi ils
vont diffuser ce film actuellement
franchement je ne comprends pas juste
avant qu'on ait les dernières infos sur
animaux vous dire à charles ix du tout
d'accord avec bio parce que là c'est un
film chorale saint firmin ya toute une
équipe bien sûr donc christian clavier
tu le condamne tu me donnes le
réalisateur tu condamnes et les
techniciens tu condamnes ce monde et
pour le coup on peut pas condamner les
gens en amont pour l'instant il est
présumé innocent et donc je trouve au
contraire tu vois pas un one man show je
trouvais ça plutôt au mexique et n'ont
fait aussi alors ils ont fait c'était la
semaine d'après moi je reste mais je
sais mais c'est plus limites mais le
film non je ne suis pas d'accord avec
toi et alors à ce moment-là ça dire que
les gens qui sont condamnées alors il
faut plus voir les films de qui ont été
produits par eux à wang xin télécharger
chargé des musiques de bertrand cantat
moïse ont été condamnés pour l'instant
rien de temps n'a pas été condamnée donc
cela mais après la chaîne c'est vraiment
posé la question c'est vrai alors voilà
l'essentiel la chaîne s'est posé la
question il ya une et une réunion de
crise avec tout le staff de dari
habitants il ya une dizaine de jours et
c'est là aussi d'ailleurs qu'ils ont
décidé que le troisième volet du film
serait finalement salle en février et du
coup quand la décision a été prise de
t'avoir le film tf1 s'est dit c'est bon
qu'on peut diffuser donc voilà les
choses ne sont pas non plus tout simple
et la question c'est vraiment posé à
téva rue alors ça mais c'est faux ce que
vous dites pas ce que ça veut dire que
les films à sortir en février quelle que
soit l'issue de longs cas normalement il
devrait sortir en séries alors attendez
ça va dépendre aussi un peu à la rispal
entre temps à vous mais moi je on sait
que voilà suite à cette cellule de crise
quand même les certaines dates de son
one man show était complètement annulé
d'autres portés en février mais on n'est
pas à l'abri qu'elle soit à nouveau
reportée
et voilà donc il se peut se passer
beaucoup de choses parce que il va se
faire voilà la sphère continue il ya une
enquête en cours sur wii nicolas
pernikoff mais non mais je pense que de
toute façon ils vont attendre le
résultat du procès ils peuvent pas
décider de ce que vous avez été choqué
non mais non mais j'ai pas été choqué
les téléspectateurs non plus 5 millions
700 mille téléspectateurs c'est quand
même un super résultat pour tf1 et de
l'autre côté je rappelle qu'il n'est pas
coupable donc pourquoi tout d'un coup
non mais pourquoi tout d'un coup on
ferait sauter tous les gens mis en
examen jugé c'est pas possible il
faudrait que je regarde
certes des programmes et sort était
entre guillemets jugé la faire à la
place de la justice et avant l'heure
mais en laissant ce film comme ils ont
laissé son one man show dans lequel il
ya des blagues un peu lourde mais en une
année c'est pas lui rendre service et ce
n'est pas lui rendre service parce que
les gens faut arrêter de ce faux dire la
vérité il ya plein de gens qui ont
allumé leur télé qui ont dit ayari
habitants et qui ont lu le film à la
lumière des accusations dont il fait
l'objet aujourd'hui donc je ne pense pas
que ça lui rendre service en réalité ils
auraient pu eux aussi faire appel
les rendre service à la non mise aux
républicains en disant contenu des
accusations dont il fait l'objet on
diffusera le film plus tard voilà c'est
tout je pense que c'est pas le conduire
les siens débat moral quand même dont
les réseaux sociaux se sont fait l'écho
faut-il faut-il alors que quelqu'un est
mis en examen diffuser ou pas tf1 s'est
posé la question et moi je le dis encore
une fois présomption d'innocence total
mais ça me choque ça me choque de voir
comme ça un film comique avec quelqu'un
qui est mis en examen pour ces raisons
là
il ya des politiques qui ont regardé en
examen
l'exemple c'est horrible je n'en sais
rien oui mais voilà après ben vous
mettez croque aussi décidé jean guilhem
examen maintenant les coupes à mauléon
en examen aujourd'hui est coupable mais
chez certains chefs d'entreprise mis en
examen s'il est gagnable un politique il
exprime des charges
mais derrière le mec c'est après un
court teaser voulait bouger sa carrière
si le mail à
tenero d'accord au meilleur chef
d'entreprise il reste dans son
entreprise là c'est une comédie il ya
cinq six mille ans ya plein de gens qui
regardent se fige la question
genre de film et que voilà et que c'est
une comédie familiale et que je pense
que ça gênait énormément de monde de
voirie habitants pour sa meute inventé
moi je découvre ses gènes étant donné
que si vous avez vous mais non mais il
ya un moment donné il faut arrêter de se
branler la tête je suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
sérieusement vous avez un mec jahjaga
14e rôles principaux dans ce film vous
allez condamner un film sur tf1 hors de
grande écoute parce qu'il ya un mec qui
est mis en examen qui n'est pas coupable
donc attendez le résultat du procès au
moins alors n'allez pas assez absurde
que ça parce qu'effectivement tf1 s'est
posée là que
vous avez faits déteste quand même pour
la mémoire
jeudi j'étais une conclusion oui mais
parce que c'est bien qu'on les garde
mais à mon avis oui d'accord mais si
c'est important et souvenez-vous
effectivement que son fils avait des
pourra mettre à laver le linge alors
les mecs vous avez des programmes s en
faut
nicolas
justice n'est pas le temps des
téléspectateurs n'est pas le temps de
l'émotion ça suscite une émotion cette
affaire non on a beaucoup parlé donc
vous pouvez pas balayer d'un trait de
plume comme ça une entrée en examen mais
c'est pas le film qui est condamné ainsi
le différend bien sûr mais là pour le
coup parce que vous êtes dur après on va
voir ce qu'on pense des spectateurs
juste myriam quelles sont les dernières
heures d'un sommet en fait j'ai pu avoir
accès au rapport médico légal de la
sphère dhr qu'en fait ce que révèle ce
rapport c'est qu'effectivement il ya eu
quelques contusions au niveau y aurait
eu j'utilise quand même le conditionner
quelques contusions au niveau du coccyx
qui ont valu à la victime présumée deux
jours d'interruption de travail indique
été harry pour l'instant il nie toujours
d'avoir agressé sexuellement cette cette
jeune femme la victime
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui je vous le cache
pas elle est selon mes infos extrêmement
mal en fait elle a des crises d'angoissé
et des grosse panique parce qu'à cause
de l'ampleur que prend leur faire à
cause de l'ampleur que prend la faire
enfin sa plus grande peur c'est que son
nom soit révélé dans la presse
donc vous donc voila et quant à areeba
lui pour l'instant tout à l'heure je
vous disais il y avait signé une réunion
de crise une dizaine de jours pour
savoir un peu comment il allait aborder
la chose pour l'instant il s'est mis au
vert chez un ami dans une maison de fin
dans la maison d'un ami en région
parisienne et voilà il se fait un peu
petit en attendant peut-être et ça ça sa
compagne elle le soutient alors ouais ça
ce n'est pas le soutien elle pourrait
même où elle est amoureuse que ça sinon
elle est amoureuse et donc malgré ce que
ce qui est sûr en tout cas dans
l'histoire on sait pas si l agression
sexuelle ou pas mais c'est parole contre
parole mais ce qui est ce qui est sûr
c'est que voilà il a trompé sa compagne
et pourtant elle est toujours là elle
pourrait même apporté son témoignage aux
dossiers en disant que bahari n'a jamais
été violent avec elle après ski ce qui
peut certainement se produire c'est que
il risque d'avoir une nouvelle
confrontation entre la victime présumée
et ary abittan janvier et je pense que
c'est à ce moment là où tout va un peu
se décider quelle va être la réaction d'
harry quelle va être la réaction la
plaignante la plaignante va être se
retirer va s'excuser enfin voilà il ya
plein d'hypothèses qui sont possibles et
je pense que c'est à ce moment là que la
carrière de dari pourra reprendre ou pas
j'ai vous donner des infos pour le
moment du côté de la victime présumée
c'est silence absolu aucune information
ne filtre aucune volonté de médiatiser
de parler alors ça peut changer dans ces
affaires là des avocats aient changé
l'avocat pour le moment dit je ne veux
absolument pas ni parler moi même ni que
ma cliente apparaissent nick rien ne
soit révélée alors c'est un juge
d'instruction également qui incite au
silence donc est-ce que ou arrêt
habitants où la victime présumée va
rompre le silence pour communiquer pour
le moment contrairement à bien d'autres
affaires du genre c'est silence absolu
alors au début nous on essayait 1
négocier avec elle une interview
exclusive avec l'anonymat et puis et
puis là vraiment elle répond plus du
tout aux appels elle veut vraiment
essayé d'un peut se faire petit blier de
gérer le stress que ça lui aurait causé
et au niveau de désinformation sur la
sortie de ses prochains films spectacles
on sait quoi les ans alors là pour
l'instant tout ce qui est son spectacle
pour de vrai tout ce qui a été prévu au
mois de novembre a été annulé il y avait
une date qui était prévu au pavillon
baltard et pour une chaussure spectacle
en fait il pourrait jouer après je pense
que voilà il a peut-être peur que les
gens
mais pourrait le faire en fait il
pourrait le faire quoi des dates qui ont
été reportés en février c'est pour ça
que s'il ya une conscience une
conciliation sienne ou une nouvelle un
nouvel arbitrage au mois de janvier lors
d'une nouvelle confrontation les choses
pourraient un peu changé donc voilà pour
l'instant les soit ça a été reporté soit
ça a été annulé voilà pour son spectacle
autour merci en tout cas on n'a même pas
le droit d'avoir été avec nous vous
revenez quand vous voulez on va penser
tout de suite maintenant je voudrais
voir le sondage couple avant de passer à
l'autre sujet merci non dit oui à 17 %
de non à 89 ans envoyé ou pas